don't
come to the dance if you ain't got paper
you know that man like to just roll with
man
tag alongs bow it's your boy lv general
lumpy slumpy my brothers don't eat
crumpets
today we are back on elvi's tracks of
the week
i hope he's not been watching them you
know if you haven't been watching and i
don't know what you've been doing
make sure you subscribe to stand out tv
make sure you subscribe to my channel
okay anyway today man's gonna be
reviewing
yeah the tune's called red card frisco
yeah featuring skepta jamaa jme and
shorty that's the whole of bbk
they've come back with a banger i
already know it's mad car
knowing me i watched grime and all that
and i saw a little snippet of it
so i thought yeah you know what this is
a bang i already know but yeah man
love always let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't piss him off blood see skeppy
different money
do you know how fast it is scare people
you know what i'm going to wear what i
want
went into a [ __ ] woman shop and
bought a girl's top
and banged it on and wore it like it was
gnomes i know i should have used that as
an example of him
but that's the type of guy he is he does
what he wants
going back to the start blood this is
[ __ ] man outside everything live man
out on job man i got fives don't know
who you said
we ain't the greatest mention grime we
are the best man i've got a window when
i go hard kill it
and then go tomorrow
[Music]
make sure you got that full clip
extended car he ain't playing games see
the man
he rolls with they take people out easy
expensive i hope you trust in your
friendship
gonna need a full clip yeah something
extended i am not your father
[Music]
i said i'm not your father what i'll go
go back i gotta go back i'm gonna go
back go to my yard go to my
[Music]
offensive i yard care what the end is no
who's in fashion i do not care what the
trend is ah that's what i said
it's old man i told matt i love it
that's harry's people's them stop
getting onto me about the fridge
stop getting unto me about the fridge
please bear comments
who's on the fridge that's that's
harry's freaking family i'm at harry's
house
this is not my house this is harry's
house what
what skeppy's mad i love graham i can't
let i love grem
[Music]
went hard every time i stepped in my
step man when he helped me in hard
everytime
me and jama we chat you get me so
man's always got banter on the phone
with him like see when i chat to jammer
he's good
people still like dead man's vibes i
like it he's a calm guy still
the way you jumped on that track there
mind came into the rhythm like it was
nothing like normal got the fans jumping
the fences every time i went in mine
went hard
every time
[Music]
don't tell me you don't know what you
meant by that
yeah cause we all play mario kart in 64
days shoot man show bow hit man spin man
now ah
spin that out yeah that type of thing
[Music]
don't come to the dance if you ain't got
paper you know what a man like to just
roll with man
tag alongs what are you ain't got peas i
broke by it man
you got that you better do your thing
allow it man
spend some money man i know an old man
back in the day he used to roll a
certain man
because they had peas and oh he's a
footballer he played for west ham
get out of there man [ __ ] they're
taking money out other people's pockets
but i want to spend your own p's joke
man
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
sick don't [ __ ] with jake listen see
jeremy
different guy brad next brother of mine
yeah ain't just skepies my
dear man of my brothers he watches all
my [ __ ] i know he's probably watching
this now
you get me blood hit me up in the
comments let them know that you're
watching this as well family i don't
into like a violation you get me man
they're shy now you watch my stuff
you don't watch my stuff but now we
linked up at wireless
last year's one he's just telling me
about good news and stuff furthermore he
was filming harry he was there
right like furthermore caught witness
right in here with us pick up my brother
anyway
[Music]
i always jump on it and disrespect it
yeah
hey frisco's [ __ ] with his butt see a
whole camp
as a collective they are [ __ ] serious
you still don't get it
[Music]
ah man said he can't ring man up
and ask man about do you know mike do
you know my again you
know i know your girl don't [ __ ] read
all that [ __ ] don't call my phone with
them crap there
man can't ring me a nose where i know
his girlfriend
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
or whatever he ate i don't know what he
said he didn't say a bomb
or not and did he because bon bons are
those little sweets then
what my mom used to buy is still back in
the day harry's looking out what the
[ __ ] are bomb bombs
[Music]
leave no evidence you get me ten years
deep and
it's still relevant it's real talk still
relevant leave no evidence
for the elements
mention crime we are the best
this is why grime won't die you know
because that these are the reasons why
it can't die
because you've got man names still
putting work in do you get me they don't
have to the 10 years deep man still no
bb case
it's normal i'll give it a strong eight
that's a strong
eight free skull red card way better
general make sure you stay tuned to
stand out tv
i've been your way elvi general over and
out love
you